this past week one of the most
controversial people on youtube
leafy got banned for life and today
i'm gonna try to sift through all the
drama surrounding his banning and
explain to you step by step what
happened
here's why leafy got the ban hammer
alright so if you like new shows like
this one you're gonna love our talk show
clouded
over on our twitch channel twitch.tv
slash the score esports
every wednesday at 1 pm eastern we go
live to talk
all of the latest news from esports
streaming and gaming
so make sure you go give us a follow and
turn on notifications so you know when
we go live
all right let's get back to this leafy
situation so if you don't know who he is
calvin leafy is here aka leafy
lee vale can only be described as well a
drama youtuber he started uploading in
2013 and got popular around 2015
for making videos about other content
creators their lives
their personalities their various beefs
and what he saw as wrong with them
and you really never know with youtubers
one day they could be completely fine
next day [ __ ] this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that youtubers cancer i'm just sitting
here like yeah i am cancer but i'm the
best [ __ ] cancer on this website
maybe his most notorious video from that
era is a now deleted video making fun of
another smaller content creator who has
a learning disability
it's safe to say that after that he
established himself as a villain
pretty quickly that said he did have a
following
leafy's fans saw his videos as just
harmless jokes
and before he got banned he had almost 5
million subscribers on youtube
around 2017 leafy took a pretty long
break from youtube
and it wasn't until recently that he got
back to making the videos he was known
for
videos about other very dramatic content
creators
like h3h3 keemstar and idubbbz
that said a lot of the story of his
eventual banning started in july
when he turned his attention to pokemon
over the course of
several videos leafy criticized
pokeman's content
her appearance and even went as far as
to say that she was
hiding a secret boyfriend from her fans
and that specific topic became
so popular after his videos that the
hashtag pokemaneboyfriend was trending
on twitter
and that prompted this joke from
pokemane who has said in the past that
she's not interested in making her love
life public on the internet leafy's
pokeman videos
all went viral and around that time
pokeman announced that she'd be taking a
long break from streaming and content
creation in general and then recently
pokeman released an apology video
discussing topics that range
all the way back to 2018 but she did
talk about some of leafy's criticisms
directly
specifically her relationship status and
his comments about her appearance
this video is to address recent comments
and criticisms that i've received
i know this video is long overdue i've
seen
a lot of people talk about the way that
i look recently
just want to put it out there i don't
think i'm the prettiest person in the
world
but i think that's okay everyone's
entitled to an opinion
i personally made the decision seven
years ago or whenever i got into
streaming that
i don't want my personal life to be a
part of my content and
that's just what i'm gonna stick by
until i and whoever i'm dating at
whatever time
decide otherwise that video was released
on august 18th
and then three days later on august 21st
leafy's entire youtube channel was gone
now youtube's policy when it comes to
violating their rules
is very similar to twitches that we talk
about all the time on this show
it's three strikes and then your own
each of the first two times you violate
a policy
you get warned and then the third time
the channel is just deleted
youtube cited quote multiple or severe
violations of youtube's policy
prohibiting content designed to harass
bully or threaten end quote as the
reason for leafy's ban
according to a tweet from slasher now
when the story about leafy's band first
broke
there was some speculation about whether
or not he was notified about his first
two strikes at all
a representative from youtube told julia
alexander a reporter from the verge that
quote
his channel was terminated because it
violated the company's harassment policy
three times over a period of 90 days
no specific videos were identified but
they did confirm
it's permanent when i asked specifically
about length of ban
end quote on august 21 after he was
banned leafy tweeted at youtube asking
how he could get his account reinstated
in response to the news another youtuber
kavos tweeted that leafy had never been
notified about his first two strikes at
all
and that his account had just been
banned out of nowhere leafy himself
also claimed he'd never been given any
strikes in a later comment that said
back on june 4th leafy actually tweeted
that he'd received two strikes on his
account for harassment there have been
some people commenting that those
strikes were reverted
but that hasn't been confirmed by leafy
himself or youtube at all on august 24th
leafy tweeted this still looking for his
account to be reinstated
and when team youtube responded he had
some choice words
as of recording this video leafy's
channel is still nowhere to be found on
youtube
and he's actually started to stream on
twitch so i guess he's trading places
with dr disrespect
now with this whole story in mind it's
worth noting that youtube has recently
made
massive changes to its policy
requirements for users
specifically the way that content
creators are supposed to treat
other content creators i've heard this
issue
in many different ways and i think we
have seen many
we've seen some high-profile examples
that we know have been
problematic and that has caused us to
take a really hard look
at our harassment policy as i'm sure
many of you know since like the
beginning of time
one of the easiest ways to become
popular on youtube is to make youtube
videos
about other youtubers this is
specifically true about what we would
call
drama content where creators beef or
call each other out
or get in extremely cringe boxing
matches
[Music]
with that said this latest situation
involving leafy
really seems to show that youtube is
taking this stuff seriously
and trying to figure out what's fair
game and what constitutes harassment
at this point with this story i think
we're just gonna have to wait and see
if leafy will ever get back on youtube
if he'll be able to stay on twitch
and if this new stricter policy is going
to have long-term implications for
other creators as well
every wednesday at 1 pm eastbourne
every wednesday at 1 pm esp wow
every wednesday at 1 pm esports week